let me tell you about the city it's in  your first cry and your last breath it's  the chain around your neck the shackles  at your feet  if you were born in the mud it will do  whatever it can to keep you there and if  you drag your way out  claw your way up there's always someone  waiting to bring you down this city  doesn't deal in favors and neither do I  sooner or later it all comes down to  power and money who has it and who  doesn't and who knows how to take it  but even the best-laid plans need to be  adaptable there is always that fly in  the ointment that thief in the night the  master thief but I understand feeds my  friends that shrinks their weaknesses  it's in my job description and he will  be caught and he will no pain  for the news